c'est une très bonne nouvelle api on est
mieux gérée de la fois sentent gérer la
décroissance
l'optimisme était de mise en février
2016 lorsque lowe's a acheté renard pour
3 milliards 200 millions de dollars
mais l'intégration de rona a été plus
difficile que prévu les ventes sont
décevantes
à la fin de l'an dernier lowe's a effacé
une valeur d'un milliard deux cents
millions de dollars dans sa filiale
canadienne
le patron de l'os canada sylvain
prud'hommes annoncé sa retraite il ya
quelques jours et un vice-président
exécutif guy beaumier vient aussi d'être
remercié joanne labrecque et professeur
à hec montréal spécialiste du commerce
de détail bonsoir qu'est ce qui se passe
chez l'autre comment ça se passe en ce
moment mais on voit que c'est quand même
une intégration le kit très difficile
alors le contexte difficile aussi
j'aurais au niveau du commerce de détail
et plusieurs défis mais rona et est une
enseigne qui était très identifiée au
québec on sait que lors de l'acquisition
est quand même eu beaucoup
d'informations qui ont d'interrogation à
savoir est ce qu'on devrait faire
laisser aller un siège social québécois
donc c'est sûr qu'il y aurait un
attachement à cet enseignant puis avoir
eu des réactions autant de la part des
affiliés que la part des consommateurs
sur certains aspects mais ils ont
également aussi le fait que les magasins
affiliés le magasin rona ce sont des
magasins qui ne sont pas de la même
taille qui ne sont pas dans des lieux
géographiques j'irai avec des marches
hic se ressemblent donc lorsque les
magasins sont un petit peu disparate et
plus difficile d'aller chercher des
économies d'échelle alors il ya deux
choses dans ce que vous dites
une désaffection possible de la
clientèle et des affiliés compte tenu de
transactions et le fait que le modèle
d'affaires et le modèle de magasins de
rona était quand même assez différent
des magasins l'eau ce qu'on voit
ailleurs au canada et aux états unis
oui alors sur cette escale est important
surtout que on arrive avec une
entreprise américaine qui ont une
culture de gestion qui est complètement
différente donc qui aussi c'est vraiment
aussi une entreprise actionnariat donc
les
les attentes des actionnaires lorsqu'on
fait une acquisition aussi importante
je ré sont aussi à la hauteur j'aurais
de l'investissement donc ces facteurs
l'ont ensemble font en sorte que trois
ans plus tard bien et on est pas on
n'est pas dans les objectifs qu'on avait
considéré que si au point de départ il
ya des réactions à l'un des moins sûres
généralement dans ce type de transaction
là ça prend 10 qu'on appelle des
synergies ou des économies d'échelle on
les trouve pas ici chez rona mais c'est
plus difficile de trouver des économies
d'échelle quand les magasins ne sont pas
identiques au modèle original puis aussi
fausse amené dans le temps où rooney
avait aussi fait des acquisitions de
différentes entreprises qui pouvaient
avoir des systèmes différents qui n'est
pas qu'il n'était pas complètement
intégré donc on arrive avec une
entreprise mère qui achète une autre
entreprise avec différents systèmes
alors l'intégration est plus difficile
puis on a vu aussi des départs où on a
vu des affiliés migrer vers d'autres
enseignes alors on voyait l'eau qui
avait quand même des réactions assez
marqué est-ce qu'il peut y avoir un
enjeu de compétent je pose la question
cruche et l'osce dans sa capacité à
intégrer une autre entreprise qui a une
culture qui est forte aussi comme rona
bien l'incompétence et la qualifier à ce
niveau aussi ils sont quand même des
détails en a qui explique qu'ils ont été
performants mais c'est pas la première
fois qu'on voit au moment où il ya une
acquisition ou il va y avoir une
dépréciation par la sucrière des
difficultés d'intégration on le vit dans
le secteur alimentaire on le veut aussi
quand target est arrivé ici donc on a
des aspirations mais les cultures sont
différentes mais aussi les systèmes sont
différents et l'énorme intérêt
d'approvisionnement actuellement sont
complètement différente avec son compère
avec le commerce électronique qui
déstabilisent j'aurai les opérations où
on doit s'adapter à ces nouvelles
d'approvisionnement plus exigeants mais
est ce qu'une incompréhension du marché
comme on a vu target arrivé ici se
casser les dents
lowe's est un groupe américain qui
arrive ici est ce qu'il ya une
incompréhension du marché québécois et
du marché canadien mais comme on avait
des gestionnaires québécois la tête donc
il y avait cette compréhension là mais
est ce que on était capable de
transférer serait de transférer la
particularité du marché québécois mais
aussi canadiens
dre ou aux gestionnaires américains
parce qu'il faut penser que les
décisions se prennent maintenant aux
états unis au caire haut lieu en
caroline donc il c'est sûr qu'il ya des
aspects de gestion qui peuvent être
dessinées ici mais le gros des
stratégies à mon avis était quand même
indiqué au niveau américain
quand on voit le pdg de l'os canada
monsieur prudhomme qui s'en va un
vice-président la radiation de plus d'un
milliard de dollars sur une transaction
quand même 2,3 milliards 200 millions
quel est donc l'avenir de rona et des
magasins rôle à l'avenir je rends court
terme
c'est vraiment l'urgence de rendre les
opérations plus efficaces plus efficient
il y aura probablement des fermetures de
magasins
mais si on n'arrive pas à redresser la
situation
moi ça me surprendrait confirme
complètement les portes parce que quand
même la grande surface plusieurs
magasins de grande surface qui
correspondent aux modèles de l'os donc
de dire qu'on va fermer les portes
complètement à mon avis est assez
improbable mais est ce qu'on pourra
venir jusqu'à une nouvelle intervention
du gouvernement du québec pour protéger
rona moi ça me surprendrait
parce que à ce niveau aussi au rona et
moins identifiés puis rooney n'est plus
rooney tels que elle était en 2016
donc et puis rona et la propriété
maintenant de notre reprise américaine
alors qu'on voit le gouvernement
intervenir pour sauver une entreprise
américaine alors la question est
difficile je vais je vois pas comment on
pourrait arriver à ce moment-là ça
voudrait dire que on pourrait intervenir
pour sauver des entreprises qui ont pour
lesquels on n'est même pas certain de
maintenir mais sèche je suis ici à
la grande question joanne labrecque
merci beaucoup pour cette analyse ce
soir sur un prix